Hi. In this video, we'll look at how you can use Burp Suite to bypass client-side controls.
Some applications rely on measures on the client side to control the data that they submit to the server.
This can lead to significant security flaws, as the user has full control over the client.
To restrict user input, applications use a range of mechanisms that prevent the user from directly seeing and modifying data.
You can use Burp Proxy to intercept a request, then modify data in the HTTP request before forwarding it to the server.
This enables you to change data in a way that may not have been possible in the application.
You can follow along using the lab Excessive Trust in Client-Side Controls from our Web Security Academy.
To view and modify data in Burp in order to bypass client-side controls, first access the page for the function you want to test in Burp's browser.
In the lab, we'll go to the product page for the leather jacket.
And then, in Burp, go to the Proxy Intercept tab and click on Intercept is off to toggle Interception on.
In Burp's browser, we can now click through the function.
Burp intercepts each request.
The message details are shown in the Intercept tab.
We can review each request for interesting content.
For example, look for parameters that are hidden on the web page.
In this example, we can see there's a hidden price parameter.
Then, edit the message.
So we're going to edit the price.
Once you've made your changes, click forward to send the request.
We can now turn Interception back off again and determine whether the modification was successfully updated on the server side.
We can do this by checking the Proxy HTTP history tab and finding the request we just edited from the edited column and reviewing the response.
You can also review the website.
In this lab, we can view the cart and see that the price has successfully changed.
We can view the cart and see that the price has successfully changed.